et
avec nous pour en parler edouard husson
historien spécialiste des relations
france-allemagne bonsoir edouard husson
merci d'être avec nous à vos côtés en
direct un petit peu plus loin jean bizet
ancien sénateur heller président de la
commission des affaires européennes
bonsoir jean bizet merci d'être avec
nous en direct un mot tout d'abord
edouard husson sur les résultats de ces
législatives un régis le sommier nous en
a parlé mais enfin on l'aura compris
difficile évidemment de constituer une
majorité
vu les miettes mandé des suffrages en
cours de ce scrutin et ça peut
clairement durer cette affaire ça peut
durer c'est très difficile de prévoir
malgré tout je pense que les systèmes
politiques tel qu'il est va essayer
d'éviter ce qui est arrivé en gala
merkel en 2017 où elle a mis six mois à
à constituer un gouvernement donc là je
crois qu'ils vont essayer d'aller plus
vite et 2 et de créer la surprise
effectivement armin laschet tu le
candidat de la cd ou s'accrochent mais
il ya quand même c'est quand même son
parti qu'elle plus perdu et donc la
dynamique est du côté du spd tout dépend
comme s'était dit tout à l'heure dans le
reportage tout dépend de la manière dont
le fdp les verts peuvent s'entendre pour
poser leurs conditions séparément et
ensemble au spd c'est pas gagné mais
il va y avoir deux politiques
expérimentés christian lindner d'un côté
roberte rabec de l'autre qui va le
prendre la main je crois pour les verts
et à ce moment là on pourrait avoir moi
je fais plutôt le pari d'un dénouement
cloud plus rapide que prévu on verra en
tout cas je vous propose d'écouter avant
de faire réagir jean bizet armin laschet
tu qui comme vous l'avez dit on
s'accroche il a refusé de jeter l'épongé
malgré le score historiquement bas de
son parti côte et
nous pouvons déjà dire que nous ne
pouvons pas être satisfaits des
résultats
mais je la fais saison qu'angela merkel
s'est présenté comme chancelière ce
furent 16 bonne année pour l'allemagne
et je tiens donc avant tout à remercier
la chancellière angela merkel pour son
travail
jean bizet clairement amina celle qui a
assumé sa part déchets que c'est
véritablement la fin de l'ère merkel 16
ans de stabilité politique en allemagne
je dirais très clairement que ça y
ressemble d'autant plus que si on
regarde un peu plus finement les
résultats on s'aperçoit si vous voulez
qu'il y à un vote générationnel entre
les anciens partis c'est deus ex ou et
spd et puis les libéraux et les verts et
la jeunesse a majoritairement choisi ces
deux derniers petits partis en quelque
sorte que non seulement vont être les
faiseurs de roi mais son sur un certain
nombre de domaines notamment dans
matière je dirais climatique transition
énergétique
ceux qui ceux qui vont compter demain
donc moi je pense que madame merkel a eu
une période assez extraordinaire elle a
été entre guillemets l'homme fort de
l'europe c'est aujourd'hui lors des
changements mais je pense qu'elle aura
encore un rôle pendant les semaines qui
viennent tout simplement parce que la
présence française devant démarrer le
1er janvier 2022 il y à fort à parier
qu'elle jouera de tout son poids pour
faire en sorte que l'allemagne soit je
dirais en position je dirais
opérationnelles
avant la présidence française alors
effectivement parce que vous l'avez dit
edwards ils sont ce précédent scrutin de
2010 est qui avait laissé un petit peu
l'allemagne en paralysie face à la scène
internationale six mois a constitué un
gouvernement ce que clairement il ya ce
risque à nouveau d'autant que comme jean
bizet l'a dit l'allemagne prend la
présidence du g 7 ans en 2022 il ya
cette crainte en tout cas en allemagne
alors je crois que si vous voulez
beaucoup dépend aussi pour pour olaf
scholz de la dynamique qui là qu'il a
créé et qui n'est pas qui n'est pas
absolument irrésistible mais qui malgré
tout existe est ce que les allemands ont
dit dans les sondages avant l'élection
ce qu'ils ont confirmé par le vote
d'hier c'est que il préférait la
personnalité de la volt et ils le
voyaient comme plus apte à gouverner
parce qu'il a une apparemment une plus
forte personnalité carmine l'achète et
donc je pense que salt n'a pas intérêt à
ce que ça s'éternise il a plutôt intérêt
à donner l'impression que avec lui les
choses redémarrent pas ce qu'il faut
nuancer un point concernant le dernier
mandat de madame merkel elle est
redevenue elle a été malgré lui à 4 ans
et elle est redevenue populaire il ya
deux ans quand on a su qu'elle ne se
représenterait plus est donc là les pour
beaucoup d'allemands il s'agit de se
remettre au travail alors la france en
tant que ex élu jean bizet la france
doit de traîtres être pendant inquiète
au moment justement où vieux continent
redoutent une forme de marginalisation
géopolitique face à certaines rivalités
des états unis on l'a vu récemment de la
chine de la russie
écoutez si nous avons salué entre
guillemets la stabilité le calme
d'angela merkel pendant ses années de
pouvoir
nous ne pouvons que regretter
elle prend sarkozy l'a exprimé avec
beaucoup plus de vigueur pendant des
années
les activités de l'allemagne et
aujourd'hui ce manque de réactivité est
d'autant plus serait d'autant plus
crucial que nous avons affaire à une
situation extrêmement délicate avec le
nouveau positionnement de la chine
lections monsieur joe biden et puis le
départ de nos amis britanniques
donc l'europe doit faire preuve de
beaucoup plus de réactivité
si elle veut se positionner dans un
environnement je dirais qu'ils ne soient
plus uniquement un dialogue entre la
chine et les états unis or là l'europe a
besoin d'un véritable rupture elles
prennent la république emmanuel macron
qui va commencer également parallèlement
sa campagne et or à l'habileté on peut
lui faire confiance surtout que à ses
côtés son conseiller europe clément
borne est particulièrement habile et
compétente pour jouer précisément cette
carte est que nous sommes vis-à-vis de
l'allemagne à l'heure des changements et
un changement de tempo il ya un
changement vecteurs et on voit très bien
que si un certain nombre de points
marquant ses parts entre guillemets les
libéraux les verts et le spd
quand on lit un peu plus en détail où on
voit qu'il ya des évolutions possibles
en france ce serait impossible mais avec
aussi c'est possible on voit très bien
que
l'autonomie stratégique
européenne et la politique de défense
les verts ont fait quelques progrès
de plus il est à parier que monsieur
chose
qui aura à écouter et à faire des
propositions l'adresse des libéraux
verra très bien ma soif je dirais de
pouvoir cette fois ci de christian
lindner et donc son souhait de
participer à une coalition
il a d'ailleurs fait savoir qu'il
voulait être le futur ministre des
finances qui n'est pas forcément une
très bonne nouvelle pour la france mais
après tout dans une coalition dans un
tel traité de gouvernement tout va se
négocier
edouard husson paris a réagi lundi
espérer avoir vite chancelier allemand
fort à ses côtés pour faire avancer
l'europe notamment durant sa présidence
tournante de l'ue à partir de janvier
comme nous l'expliqué jean bizet
l'europe est à un moment charnière de
son histoire
les pro européens doivent-ils sans
inquiéter justement de tous ces
changements aussi bien du côté de
l'allemagne peut-être de la france dans
quelques mois on ne sait pas alors je
crois si vous voulez que
il est difficile d'imaginer que le
président français quel que soit son
influence en europe est la capacité à
faire accélérer le jeu politique
allemand il ya beaucoup de choses qui
nous échappent et moi je crois par
conséquent qui a peut-être une carte à
jouer
une carte à jouer qui est celle de se
dire on va être effectivement face au
premier gouvernement allemand tripartite
dont le rythme de décision va forcément
être plus long que ce qu'il était jusque
là et donc c'est à la france de savoir
ce qu'elle veut alors effectivement de
donner l'impulsion ya peut-être une une
fenêtre de tir là pour qui les liait
finalement une réaffirmation
d'une forme de de présence plus forte
dans le dans le partenariat franco
allemand du côté de la france avec
simplement un bémol à m c'est que à la
fin de son quinquennat emmanuel macron
laisse une france très endetté et que ça
ça ne passe pas en allemagne et ça
disons que ça affaiblit beaucoup de ses
prises de position il sait demande et
donc je crois que l' équilibre subtil
c'est effectivement préparer la
présidence de l'union européenne mais
c'est aussi en même temps qu'ils se
projettent vraisemblablement vers une
campagne de pour solliciter sa
réélection de montrer aux allemands que
il n'y a pas une espèce de deux courbes
toujours ascendante des déficits
français et qu' il y a des efforts qui
seront faits parce que sinon il y aura
ce rythme très lent de la politique
allemande et une france peu crédible et
à ce moment là on n'avancera pas on
restera dans l'entre-deux où on est
actuellement et jean visait justement on
connaît les allemands très attachés à
cette rigueur
budgétaire au sein de l'europe quel que
soit aujourd'hui la coalition ce sera
d'une certaine manière la même chose
pour la france où il faudra se plier
justement à certaines exigences en
fonction
c'est une évidence et c'est le grand
temps de entendent tendon d'achille de
la france et son taux d'endettement et
ça
faculté à
se réformer avec beaucoup de réticence
mais au delà
les matic franco allemand les chiffres
ne peuvent pas mentir et on voit très
bien que ce soit du côté de la fed du
côté de la banque centrale européenne
est bien la politique si je puis dire
des taux va évoluer et on voit très bien
que quelques dixièmes de ton
supplémentaires sur les emprunts faut
faire en sorte que la dette va de plus
en plus devenir littéralement
insoutenable pour le france donc
au delà de la vue-des-alpes mans c'est
un impératif national
auquel on ne pourra pas échapper
alors c'est vrai aussi qu'on se pose
parfois nous observateurs
la question de cette relation entretenue
par le couple franco-allemand
illustration en pleine crise des
sous-marins qu'on a vécu ici même la
semaine dernière berlin qui signent un
partenariat
spatiale un militaire avec l'australie
comme on le voit sur ces images c'était
la une du figaro cette même semaine
l'accord sur ariane 6 nous et mi juillet
entre la france et l'allemagne qui entre
en vigueur avec pour conséquence directe
le transfert outre-rhin de la production
du moteur de la fusée
spatiale
regardez cette une d'ailleurs de lusine
nouvelles dont 860 salariés à vernon
dans l'eure qui vont en faire les frais
edouard husson ça vous inspire quoi ça
ce sont voilà les jeux de 2 entre amis
ou faut qu'ils s'en sont inquiétés de ce
qu'on entend c'est curieusement c'est si
vous voulez je crois qu'il ya rien de
nouveau
au sens où l'allemagne a toujours
considéré que c'est pas parce qu'on est
amis qu'il n'y a pas une une émulation
une compétition ça s'appelle l'ordo
libéralisme et donc chacun joue sa carte
en respectant les règles partagées
cependant si vous voulez je crois que
cet enchaînement d'événements que vous
avez très bien
synthétisé devrait être l'occasion d'une
prise de conscience assez rapide à paris
que effectivement ça ne ça ne peut pas
continuer comme ça nous avons aussi des
intérêts à défendre et ses intérêts il
faut les défendre effectivement dans le
cadre européen mais de manière beaucoup
plus beaucoup plus clair vis-à-vis de
nos amis allemands qui eux si vous
voulez quand le chancelier kohl
autrefois disait l'allemagne et l'europe
sont les deux faces d'une même monnaie
ou l'europe et l'allemagne 10 et il a
l'intention de ses de ses compatriotes
il faut pas il faut pas oublier que ça
voulait dire que en europe l'allemagne
entendait être pleinement elle même et
je pense d'ailleurs que c'était la
conception aussi qu'avec général de
gaulle delà de la communauté économique
européenne et il serait temps de ce
point de vue là que ça soit macron de où
monsieur x il serait temps de revenir à
cette scène conception des choses parce
que sinon effectivement le couple
franco-allemand s'étiolera justement
coup d'oeil sur les principaux dans la
lignée de ce qu'on vient de dire sur les
principaux partenaires commerciaux de
l'allemagne ce sont les chiffres gardé
de l'office fédéral de la statistique
allemand pour 2017 on constate un que la
chine et les etats-unis sont les
premiers partenaires commerciaux de
berlin je me pose la même question jean
bizet sol et les allemands jouent
vraiment le la carte de l'europe et
faut-il al'inverse être peut-être
davantage nous aussi nationaliste
je pense qu'il faut davantage d'europe
en la matière si je reviens de seconde
sur la sphère des sous marins qui est
totti qui ne se résume pas simplement à
la vente je dirais de bâtiments mais les
noël et comme engagé les australiens ont
aussi acheté la paix avec la rage la
participation des états unis d des
anglais dans cette affaire mais je pense
que ce dossier aurait peut-être eu une
autre allure si précisément l'europe
avait su s'entendre en la matière si
navale groupe avait su s'entendre avec
thyssen krupp sur le sujet tant que nous
n'aurons pas une intégration
je dirais supplémentaire que ce soit en
matière de fédéralisme budgétaire on a
tout petit début de fédéralisme
budgétaire suite à l'épidémie qu'ovide
tant que nous ne ferons pas davantage je
dirais de politique économique plus
intégrée et bien on aura des des
dossiers comme ceux ci on aura des
poussée de nationalisme
ce qui est assez malsain
le mot de la fin pour vous partager
une vision un peu différente
je pense que nous sommes nous sommes à
un tournant pour la politique française
qui doit qui doit en fait revenir
à une conception - fédéraliste et plus
plus plus gaullienne on dira où l'europe
se fait par les états membres et je
crois que là le grand problème le grand
problème que rencontre la france
actuellement vis-à-vis de son partenaire
allemand c'est que nous ne sommes plus
assez fort le partenariat est devenu
asymétrique et donc je crois que il ya
là avec un gouvernement allemand faible
ce qui n'empêchera pas l'industrie
allemands de continuer à tourner les les
ingénieurs allemands de continuer à
travailler les scientifiques allemands
de continuer à innover et bien nous
avons malgré tout une occasion
historique c'est puisque nous aurons une
allemagne plus morcelé politiquement
peut-être que nous nous pouvons faire
preuve de plus de cohésion et mieux
savoir ce que nous voulons et le dire à
nos amis allemands merci en tout cas
tous les deux edouard husson j'ai remisé
d'avoir été avec nous pour ce décryptage
ce soir merci